[Music]
you know I've gotten this down to an
asterism which is Rome Falls nine times
an hour and your job as you clean up in
the kitchen and fold your socks and go
to your job is to feel every time it
fall and everything else happening it
all everything happens
nine times an hour and once a day and
twice a week and three times the years
it's all going on on different scales
and what the actual experience of being
alive is is being embedded in this
standing wave form of temporal
interference you know in linear theory
the most important moment in terms of
its effect on this moment is the moment
which just preceded this moment but in
this theory it says no the most
important moment shaping this moment is
a galaxy of moments scattered through
time some of them in millions of years
ago some of them seconds ago some of
them centuries ago and together they
create the incredible rich effect Laden
environment that we call being a
thinking human being paying attention
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]